this was the police said a very
different night of protests in
Minneapolis burning buildings looting
and violence an escalation as the anger
and tension rises crowds protesting at a
police station were driven back with
tear gas a man died after a shooting at
a pawn shop it is the video of the last
moments of George Floyd's life
a police officers knee on his neck
that's driven the outrage his family and
the city's mayor calling for the officer
to be charged with murder why is the man
who killed George Floyd not in jail if
you had done it or I had done it we
would be behind bars right now and I
cannot come up with a good answer to
that question the protests have now
spread in Los Angeles crowds blocked a
freeway and clashed with police the
anger over the treatment of
african-american men by police isn't new
but it is very raw right now
fueled by things like this a white man
confronting black businessman in the
office jeans we ever office here this
guy came accusing us we can't be here
man's had his lease
terminated the actor John boyega posted
his frustrations a black man was just
murdered in cold blood in the streets
stateside again while saying that he
can't breathe that's a continuous cycle
going on and although I don't live in
the States but on black dad so I say
again you racist white people that
frustration is shared by America's
politician to watch mr. Floyd be
murdered in a video at a time when we're
all so sad to begin with it's always
tragic it has always been tragic but
there we saw on on TV and being murdered
on TV in Minneapolis the community's
feeling is clear Donald Trump has said
justice will be served but it could take
weeks for a prosecutor to decide on
criminal charges and people here are
impatient for answers Gregg Milam Sky
News Los Angeles